وزير الخارجية مكلف برئاسة الوزراء،
ورئيس الوزراء يقود جبهات القتال،
الحشود تزحف لتطوق العاصمة،
والمعارك تحتدم بين المتمردين والحكومة الإثيوبية،
وهؤلاء جميعهم ليسوا في فعالية ترفيهية!
بل هم أسرى من الجيش الإثيوبي في يد المتمردين،،
يا إلهي ما الذي يحدث؟
هل أصابت إثيوبيا لعنة النيل والفراعنة؟...
إثيوبيا التي أعلنت استعدادها للحرب ضد مصر
بسبب سد النهضة ها هي اليوم لا تستطيع دحر المتمردين من أبناء جلدتها،
الحرب على أشدها، والأمم المتحدة تدعو الطرفين إلى ضبط النفس
وعدم الانجرار أكثر في الحرب الأهلية،
فما الذي يحدث في إثيوبيا اليوم؟
في العام ٢٠١٨ تولى آبي أحمد رئاسة الحكومة في إثيوبيا
وأعلن عن إصلاحات سياسية، فما هي هذه الإصلاحات يا آبي أحمد؟...
جاءت أبرز الإصلاحات بتنحية قادة في الجيش والمخابرات
من أبناء إقليم تيغراي، وتعيين قادة من قوميتي الأمهرة والأورومو في مواقعهم، ..
تعمقت الأزمة بعد ذلك، ثم تأجلت انتخابات ٢٠٢٠،
بسبب جائحة كورونا، ودخلت البلاد في أزمة دستورية، ،،
في إقليم تيغراي تم تنظيم انتخابات من طرف المعارضة،
لكن الحكومة رفضت النتائج،
وهنا بدأ النزاع المسلح في نوفمبر ٢٠٢٠،
عندما تدخلت الحكومة الإثيوبية بجيشها في الإقليم،
وأقامت انتخابات لسلطة محلية جديدة،
وما هي إلا أشهر قليلة واستطاعت معارضة تيغراي، استعادة عاصمتهم ميكلي،
وأعلنت الحكومة وقف إطلاق النار،
ومنذ ذلك اليوم لم تعرف المنطقة الاستقرار، ،
أعلنت ٩ مجموعات متمردة -
من بينها جبهة تحرير تيغراي-تحالفها، ضد الحكومة الفيدرالية برئاسة آبي أحمد،
وهنا دعت حكومة آبي أحمد جميع منتسبي القوات المسلحة السابقين
لإعادة تجنيدهم للقتال ضد المتمردين،
ونظمت الحكومة أيضا مظاهرات ومسيرات حاشدة
لدعم جهودها ضد المتمردين تحت شعار
(لن نضحي بحريتنا)
فيما تم تكليف وزير الخارجية في الحكومة الإثيوبية
بمهام رئيس الوزراء، بعد أن تولى رئيس الوزراء آبي أحمد
القيادة في جبهات القتال...
لكن ما هو موقف المتمردين والمعارضين من هذه الأحداث؟
في المقابل جبهة تيغراي مع حلفائها تتوعد بالزحف نحو العاصمة أديس أبابا،
التي تبعد عن قواتهم أقل من ٤٠٠ كم،
بينما تزحف قواتهم أيضا شرقا باتجاه بلدة ميلي على الطريق المؤدي إلى جيبوتي،
مما يهدد بإغلاق خط إمداداتٍ أساسي لأديس أبابا.
..
أما الحكومة فقد حشدت قرابة ٢٨ ألف شاب،
للمساعدة في العملية الأمنية في العاصمة أديس أبابا
وأعلنت حالة الطوارئ،،
لكن ماذا عن الحرب ضد مصر يا حكومة آبي أحمد؟
وماذا لو قررت مصر أن تستغل أوضاع إثيوبيا وتضرب سد النهضة؟
حكومة إثيوبيا أعلنت أنها جاهزة للحرب ضد مصر
وهي في الحقيقة لم تستطع صد جماعات من المتمردين!!!
...
وبينما تحاول الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية جمع الطرفين على طاولة واحدة للتفاوض،
تحاول الحكومة الإثيوبية فرض شروطها للجلوس مع المتمردين
الذين لن يقبلوا أية شروط للتفاوض،
خصوصا وقد أصبح المتمردون في موقع قوة،،،
...
فإلى أين سيؤول الوضع في إثيوبيا؟
وما هو موقف مصر من الوضع الحالي لمن يحاولون أخذ حقهم من مياه النيل؟...